and right there in less than a second I
have created a tool that allows me to
overcome all of my physical limitations
my name is bill Schindler I'm an
experimental archaeologist and primitive
technologist and a professor of
archeology and anthropology at
Washington College if you're in the
wilderness and you have nothing the most
important thing that you need is a sharp
durable edge humans are one of the
weakest species on the planet our nails
are almost useless our teeth are almost
useless we're not that strong we can't
run very fast we can't dig into the
ground we need tools to overcome these
physical limitations and interact with
our environment and without those tools
we will die the production of stone
tools can vary from the simplest most
basic tool that can be made in less than
a second to something that takes hours
or days to make and is incredibly
complex the process is actually quite
simple
remember our australopithecines
ancestors with the brains the size of my
fist figured out how to do this on their
own and you can do it yourself as well
so here's my piece of Flint or here's my
rock that I'm gonna strike I'm gonna
find an edge that hopefully is less than
90 degrees and ideally around 70 degrees
where you see me with my finger I'm
gonna take a hammer stone the mass of
the hammer stone is usually less than
the mass of the size of the rock I'm
trying to hit and I'm gonna hold it in
my hand away from my body these flakes
coming off a razor sharp strike the rock
right there in less than a second I have
made a tool that's sharper and more
durable than anything that I have on my
body even something like carving this
piece of wood everything that I'm doing
right now is something that I can't do
with any other part of my body I can use
this sharp edge to carve with to scrape
with to slice butcher I can even use it
as a wedge and to split the stick in
half this is the only tool that I need
to make an entire fire kit to make fire
this is the only tool that I need to
butcher an entire animal this is
incredibly powerful and this is what
made us human
when you're looking for the right kind
of rock to make a stone tool from there
are four properties you're looking for
the rock needs to be homogenous in other
words whatever the structure is on the
inside you want it to be the same
throughout you're sending shockwaves
into this rock and you don't want them
to be interrupted it needs to be brittle
in other words when you strike it it
needs to fracture with a crack you don't
want it to crumble
you also need it to be elastic when you
strike this rock the flake that you're
creating actually bends off and then
snaps back and finally it needs to be
isotropic and by isotropic I mean that
the same rules apply no matter what
direction I hit this rock a piece of
slate is not isotropic slate is perfect
for shingles because if I strike it in
one direction it Cleaves off in two
sheets by striking in the other
direction it's gonna crumble this rock
this piece of Flint if I strike it from
this direction or this direction or this
direction the same rules apply you need
to remember that it is a predictable
process this predictable process is best
illustrated right here with this piece
of glass this is a Hertzian cone if you
look at the angle it's almost a hundred
and thirty six degrees what's important
is if I did the same thing every single
time and I created this by taking this
piece of plate glass and dropping a BB
on it the same exact cone with the same
exact angle would pop out every single
time and if that's the case then I can
start to control certain things so if I
tip this piece of glass so that the BB
hittin it wasn't hitting it at 90
degrees the cone would have a different
shape if I tipped it the other way it
would have a different shape back in the
other direction so what does that have
to do with making stone tools well
instead of hitting it in the middle of
this glass what if I moved it to the
edge and the piece that popped out was
half of a cone and that's exactly what
happened here this flake that came out
of this rock is a part of that Hertzian
cone and I can control that shape and
that size by kill ting that rock and
hitting it with different things what
does this look like in real life and
what are you looking for and how do you
strike these rocks in order to create
these very basic tools
well again you have to find the right
kind of rock rock
like flint for example or court sites or
obsidians those are ideal rocks to use
to make stone tools if I took this rock
for example this flake came out for this
parent one here instead of just using
the sharp edge on it I could envision on
the inside of this rock a finished knife
something just like this and I can
strategically attack this rock change
angles change what I hit it with to
remove all the parts that I don't want
so a finished blade like this would be
produced from the inside
I'm gonna use this rock very quickly and
show you what it looks like to create
this unify so tool and it's something we
call a by facial tool in other words I'm
gonna control two phases of this rock at
the same time one of the things you'll
notice is that I'm flipping this rock
over I'm looking for angles I'm looking
for certain types of morphology on the
surfaces that I'm gonna follow and I'm
starting to get a general outline of
what I'm looking for here is a very
basic hand axe the technology I use to
just create that flake the technology
that's almost three and a half million
years old the technology that I'm using
here now to create this hand axe is two
million years old in addition to
striking the rock with all sorts of
things I can also modify the shape of
the rock by pushing pieces off and this
is where you what you do when you really
find work for resharpening creating
notches and arrowheads adjusting angles
so in order to do that I can use a
variety of materials I can use a piece
of wood I can use an antler
you can increase leverage by taking
pieces of antler and strapping them to
pieces of wood and this is how it works
if I want to adjust the shape or the
sharpness of something small like this
unfinished arrowhead I could put it in
my hand take the tip put it exactly
where I want it to be and push flakes
off this is a an extremely predictable
process because I can put
the tip of this antler exactly where I
want it to be I can line up the angle of
the force that I want to initiate and
then press the force off this is really
the beginning of it all once you've
created your stone tool you can create
shelter you can create a fire kit you
can create hunting weapons you can
create a tool that allows you to dig
into the ground and harvest underground
storage organs like roots or corns or
tubers because of this tool you can not
only survive but you can thrive in the
wilderness
[Music]